[Music]
when out to our bachelor date night
exclusive only we were invited to Ari's
first one-on-one date of the season and
it came with quite the stylish surprise
in the form of designer rachel doe today
is all about you and I have a little
surprise for you
if you look over there there she is
[Music]
and while the twenty-seven-year-old
publicist Becca got a private dress
fitting with the celeb stylists I feel
like I mean it's cliche but I feel like
Cinderella what girl doesn't love to
dress up in beautiful gowns it's crazy
re pastime eating I just grabbed the big
plate of chocolates and and and fruit
yeah I ate a lot during the season it
was quite funny actually well he also
indulged in a little spending rachel
says he bought five of the gowns for
Rebecca this one alone is worth more
than a thousand bucks I mean I was
definitely trying to charm her a small
change for the pro racecar driver tried
a real estate agent re is worth a
reported four million dollars his dad
who also raced in the indie series is
worth a reported 20 million Wow tell us
about what you saw between Ari and Becca
today what do you think of their
connection the fact that they just met
was bizarre because they seemed very
connected yep our cameras caught a lot
of touching hand-holding and lip-locking
oh my god he's such a good kisser I can
see why he got that nickname the kissing
bandit I want more
[Music]